welcome back to new rockstars i'm eric
voss and marvel's eternals just released
in 4k allowing us to spot lots of new
details so i'm going to scrub back
through this movie frame by frame to
break down the new goodies now i will be
covering some stuff that i already
covered in my opening weekend breakdown
i'm sorry to repeat myself but you know
not everyone caught this movie when it
came out and i want to try to be as
comprehensive as arashim is when he
tells cersei how pointless everything is
the film opens with a star wars style
scrawl beginning with the words in the
beginning the first three words of the
bible of course establishing this film
as its own book of genesis of the mcu it
mentions the six singularities capital s
lending some sacred status to the six
infinity stones and the number six may
connects to these celestials having six
eyes now if the celestials predate the
big bang what universe existed before
this could also remind you of galactus
who in marvel lore was an explorer named
galen who lived in the pre-big bang
universe now this script also says the
unnatural deviants came from deep space
and that the eternals came from a planet
named olympia making all this a lie like
should we also doubt the peaceful
balance boasted here especially if you
look closely ereshim appears to have
some interesting battle scars cracked
into his armor suggesting he might have
been involved in some past celestial
conflict that might have caused the
beheading of the celestial nowhere on
the domo the craggy statue of aeroshem
beams together the speaking sphere from
a hand that i just noticed this and
makes this shape which in asl means
[ __ ] dude come on makari is sitting
right in front of you it's just
appropriate that this celestial a-hole
greets us like this now as that cosmic
energy activates each of the eternals it
starts with ajax then strings to cersei
then to drink which might show us the
order of succession because cersei
replaces ajax and after her druid was
really the most outspoken leader icarus
is at the far end of that though the
last one to be activated showing how he
was never intended to be the real leader
of this group he was really just a
soldier who blindly follows orders and
since we later learned these are all
synthetic means it's just awesome that
they all boot up as a kind of electrical
circuit like nodes on a string of
christmas lights now framed in the
sunlight of earth dead center is
mesopotamia which anthropologists have
called the fertile crescent of human
civilization the date is 5000 bc which
really is our earliest records of
civilization dating back to the ancient
sumerians who started in this region now
our first shot of human technology in
this film is this close-up of a dull
blade used to play a fish this same tool
that cersei later at the end of the
sequence transforms into a more ornate
and sharper dagger and this is actually
based on a real-life relic recovered
from a royal tomb in the sumerian port
city of ur which we are probably looking
at here now you'll notice the predator
deviant has four eyes one rung down from
the celestial six eyes but one rung up
from humans and eternals just little
evidence showing that the celestials
actually created the deviants first
before the eternals and humans now as
you've noticed by watching these videos
it's rare that i ever get cold feet when
it comes to a theory but sometimes i get
cold feet because my feet are literally
wet wet socks suck especially this time
of year but to keep your toes warm and
dry you don't have to resort to wearing
some big old nasty boots you can wear
some sleek comfortable vessy shoes thank
you to bessie for sponsoring this video
messi's are the perfect everyday shoe
they are sustainably made knit sneakers
that are 100 waterproof to keep your
winter feet dry and warm without any of
the clunkiness of boots and as a bonus
they are great in warm weather too like
me these bad boys work all day every day
they are made with this diamond text
material that is super easy to clean
with just a rinse of water oh no
i spilled water all over my feetsy
weezies but my oinky oinkies are bone
dry like the dune sea
thanks messy whatever the season vases
are a truly everyday shoe banish those
soggy socks forever i don't know what
exit this is i'm just excited about
these shoes so check out vesty in the
link below and use the code new
rockstars to get 25
off your vessy shoes the eternals ice
makari kingo and gilgamesh and thena
take down the deviants icarus throughout
this is framed with the glare of the sun
behind him as he later is in this movie
at babylon foreshadowing his fate flying
directly into the sun like the
mythological narrative of icarus that's
bright based on him the domo looms into
view on the coast in a dark rectangular
shape and frame evoking the mysterious
arrival of the monolith in stanley
kubrick's 2001 space odyssey which also
reframes the dawn of man and the advent
of technology with extraterrestrial
guidance you'll notice how the stitching
on all the eternals outfits and their
tech and their energy takes the form of
circles concentric circles overlapping
circles symbolizing their own true
nature as synthetic beings locked in a
cycle with no beginning no end of
planetary caretaking and destruction to
gestate the birth of new celestials now
the moment cersei gives the dagger to
the boy evokes michelangelo's creation
of adam when god sparked consciousness
into mankind a painting which
michelangelo awesomely designed framing
god in the shape of a human brain
consciousness from within this close-up
of the hands touching each other on the
beach also mirrors one of the closing
shots of the film when cersei gives
sprite the gift of mortality like the
blueberry with pinocchio now the music
we hear here is pink floyd's time the
opening track of their album dark side
of the moon the lyrics lament losing
track of time kicking around on a piece
of the ground waiting for someone or
something to show you the way the
eternals have been stuck on earth
burning time for centuries for millennia
waiting for further instructions from
the celestials the marvel studios title
card which normally flashes pages of
avengers comics now instead flashes
comic artwork from jack kirby depicting
the celestials and then it fades in iron
man and the rest also you'll notice
has been added to the m of marvel
studios in london above the screen for
that dagger is a promo for the grc
global repatriation council which we
learn about in the falcon the winter
soldier that's the organization that
resettles victims of thanos's snap after
the blip at london's natural history
museum cersei eyes a whale skeleton
actually in a deleted scene sprite
projects over these fossils the flesh of
deviants suggesting that cersei may
actually be wary of the predator that
these remains used to be and she agrees
charles darwin as charlie meaning his
whole theory of evolution probably came
from some chats with her dean whitman
quotes the poet walt whitman in this
fraud earth of ours amid the measureless
grossness and the slag
enclosed and safe within its central
heart nestles the seed perfection
foreshadowing the seed of the celestial
tiamet nestled in the central heart of
this broad earth cersei meanwhile
lectures about apex predators which also
foreshadows the eternals coming conflict
with the deviants in this movie cersei
gives dane this ring for the middle ages
with his family crest it depicts a raven
with its wings folded back this is the
crest of the black knight marvel's
bearer of the ebony blade dating all the
way back to dane's ancestor of sir
perseus scandia a contemporary of merlin
and king arthur later on in the film
cersei talks to dane about his uncle and
in the final scene dane begins to tell
her about that turns out my family
history is
complicated
all setting up the post-credits scene
where dane finds himself in the mansion
of his uncle and recovers the ebony
blade in a box marked morris mihi lucrum
death is my reward and he hears this
voice sure you're ready for that mr
whitman that is mahershala ali as
marvel's blade setting up a possible
team up between these two in the comics
they both work on a supernatural fight
and team mi13 but i'm wondering in the
mcu they might work together as part of
the midnight suns alongside moon knight
in the camden lock part of london you'll
notice the band posters on the wall
include mentions of electric god and
stick to the plan kind of like these
electrical analog gods are really tasked
with sticking to ayrshim's plan now when
sprite falls her illusions fade because
unlike loki her illusions aren't
tangible duplication casting a
distinction that loki explained in his
series illusion projection involves
depicting a detailed image from outside
oneself which is perceptible in the
external world whereas duplication
casting entails recreating an exact
facsimile of one's own body in its
present circumstance which acts as a
true holographic mirror of its molecular
structure now the mural behind this
whole deviant fight depicts a tiger a
wolf a rhino and more framing the
deviant as yet another apex predator
richard madden and kit harrington give
each other a knowing look when they meet
recalling their past screen time
together on game of thrones where the
last words they exchanged were next time
i see you you'll be all in black
it was always my color and now he is
greeting marvel's black knight dane asks
why didn't you guys help fight thanos or
any war all the other terrible things
throughout history now genealogically
thanos is an eternal but born with a
deviant gene actually chloe zhao
explained in an interview with empire
that thanos and his brother eros were
eternals with similar roles on the
planet titan and that she imagined this
as why thanos was so worried about
overpopulation while eros deserted his
mission they watched mcu news service
w-h-i-h on the tv and you'll notice how
sprite unsheathes that dagger this is
the same dagger that she uses to stab
cersei in the back during the final
battle the babylon battle goes down in
front of the famous ishtar gate of
babylon pieces of which can also now be
found in museums inside that city are
the hanging gardens of babylon one of
the seven wonders of the ancient world
ajax is summoned to arashim voiced by
david k who voices optimus prime in the
transformers this first shot only shows
part of his massive head and it's
impossible for us to take him all in at
once at this point in the movie really
he's only personified through his voice
and through his eye holes of which we
only see four which is the number of
deviant eyes giving them a more
miniscene appearance here i also like
how chloe zhao uses ajax's tiny tiny
body to give us a sense of scale in
comparison to the eye holes so when
tiamat rises from the indian ocean and
when airshim returns to the sky in the
final scene we now know from these
opening shots how immense these things
truly are now at the feast sprite
reframes the battle that they just
witnessed into the actual epic of
gilgamesh from our history mentioning
both gilgamesh and in kiru a character
from the epic whom gilgamesh defeats and
then the two become friends makari
barters for the emerald tablet which is
another real world relic of cryptic
hermetic texts that's poured over by
islamic and european alchemists who
associated it with the philosopher's
stone as a means of producing gold and
contains the famous derived passage as
above so below which is kind of cool to
think about in the context of the
celestials right as they are above so is
another celestial below our feet cersei
tries to show icarus how to make their
bread and he just chucks the dough down
sloppily but she gently pats it flat i
just like this little gesture setting up
the conflict in the final battle icarus
just makes a mess of everything but
cersei wins by knowing exactly how to
lay her hands now in their wedding i
love this shot of the other eternals
sprite looks pissed because she's
envious she's a tinkerbell to this peter
pan and thena gives this apprehensive
stare because she never fully trusted
icarus now as they drive up to ajax
ranch in south dakota notice how the
terrain is cracked their car has to hop
over it just showing how that earthquake
that they felt in london was really a
worldwide one preceding tiamat's
emergence now heading into the house
icarus is the last one to walk in since
he knows what they're going to find and
he doesn't want the other two to see and
judge his reaction though technically he
doesn't lie when he says what killed her
exactly it was a deviant
because we see later on all he does is
really push her into that ice glacier
pit and it's the deviants who kill her
but after cersei becomes the prime
eternal icarus's envy reveals itself did
you talk with arsham are you sure you
talked to darshan which is why instead
he suggests that she just might be
suffering from mad weird and to figure
out what mad worry is we flash back to
the eternals debating over that 1521
spanish conquest of the aztec empire at
tenochtillon sorry i mispronounced it
though we should know despite druid
ending this particular battle spanish
forces overall still conquered the
americas at that time thanks in part to
carrying diseases with them like
smallpox athena's mad weary kicks in and
she an ajax duel ajax gets stabbed in
her palm making a stigmata wound and
later gets stabbed in her side as christ
was at the time of his crucifixion
foretelling her own murdered him notice
how ajax almost snaps thena out of it
you are safe
you are loved
you're arthena
yes those gunshots are what return
thena's mind to violence
showing that it's really human genocide
that triggers her memories of the
genocide that they committed on other
planets kingo stars in a bollywood film
where his costume is based on icarus's
design he introduces them to carroon oh
karon he's worked with me for 50 years i
trust him completely
actually when we first met he thought i
was a vampire and he tried to stake me
through the heart yes a little reminder
that vampires do exist in the mcu
setting up blades cameo in the
post-credits scene then kingo says i
can't just go i mean all these people
depend on me we just started shooting
this movie it's the first of a trilogy
we just got bts to do a cameo like
i like the meta nods here to marvel's
own franchise building and how they were
able to score a massive pop star to do a
cameo in this movie then on kingo's
private jet he collects captain
america's original shield from the first
capped film and if you remember the
guards in the background of his
bollywood number also carry shields with
a similar design pattern as captain
america's you'll notice on the tv screen
behind icarus throughout the scene
actually plays the empire strikes back
the scene where han is frozen in the
carbonite in kingo's documentary cersei
says i can change
a rock into
water i i could turn a rock into wood
or a rock into metal kingo brushes it
off but this does seem to foreshadow
cersei's miraculous transfiguration in
the final battle behind kingo is six
movie posters showing his various
bollywood franchises over five
generations all of which would have been
within a hundred years of cinema's
existence which means kingo refused to
wait for whatever branch of his family
tree to just get slightly older and
instead like after 15 or 20 years or so
would just change his facial hair to
play whoever this famous actor's still
handsome son is like he didn't bother
spacing it out to just like three
generations of himself in australia
gilgamesh meets karoon i'm karon
kingo's vale
o vale like alfred in batman yes one of
two dc references made in this film
along with ted that's superman jack it's
really funny jack that is definitely not
super superman this is part of chloe
zhao's goal to really embrace all of
superhero mythology as something that
was really rooted in eternal's history
athena suffers from mad weary again
everyone in century 6 is going to die
it's too late
we can't say yes century 6 is a lesser
planet for marvel comics from thor 256 a
planet whose population gets sold into
slavery here this was a past planet that
the eternals helped the celestials
destroy to sprout a new celestial baby
as sprite turns gilgamesh into a big
baby he says yours is a secret bro
all didn't taught me as a thank you
thank you
love his army
yeah this is a huge detail that i missed
before the battle of tonsburg in 965 a.d
that was seen in the thor prologue when
odin beat the frost giants and took loki
as his ward this whole battle was won
thanks to help from the eternals meaning
odin knew about the eternals they were
all friends and if odin knew about them
and if thor followed kingo around as a
kid characters like loki like hella and
valkyrie might also know about the
eternals and yeah we do hear kingo say
thor used to follow me around when he
was a little kid now he's a famous
adventurer and won't return my calls i
just would love to see this relationship
pursued further in titles like thor love
and thunder a movie that's going to have
a villain like gore the godbutcher who i
think might be targeting all celestial
linked deity figures sprite says so now
that captain rogers and iron man are
both gone who do you think is to lead
the avengers
i could lead them yeah i like how sprite
calls steve captain rogers meaning of
course they were aware of him back in
the 1940s when he was an army soldier
and also might be a nod to the fact that
captain american mcu is technically now
sam wilson cersei communes with aeroshim
and i love how this guy is always
revealing himself his huge massive frame
just on the other side of whatever
nearby surfaces they're in in earth like
he's always right there
leaning in your face watching and some
more amazing scale here as we zoom out
from cersei and then a massive wall of
red blocks her from our view which then
reveals itself as just one of arashim's
fingers airshim depicts tiamat's
terrifying emergence from earth timoth's
hand crashing up through the crust
causes the power grids of all the nearby
cities to flicker out actually before
the whole cities flicker out you can see
the little tiny power plants of those
cities flickering out first we visit the
world forge which has tunnels snaking
into it with tiny bits of light which
are for each eternal returning to be
rebooted here the interior of the forge
is structured with a steampunk design of
gears and rings like the inside of a
clock as airship explains the deviance
evolution one deviant attacks these
green-skinned humanoids we might be
looking at early versions of scrolls
because the scrolls originated from the
planet torfa and the squirrels were
considered the deviant strain of that
species then onto drug's amazon village
we see a blacksmith hammering away like
tony stark in the cave in iron man
actually come to think the way fastos
designs all of his technology in this
movie using his holographic interface is
also pretty similar to the way stark
operates when dane calls cersei playing
lizzo's juice notice the photo on her
screen shows dane with his black knight
raven family ring that ring is framed
once again during their facetime what
about king midas everything he touched
turned to gold was that you dame
confucius call your uncle what
my uncle you've always wanted to make
amends with him right now dane whitman's
uncle is nathan garrett the previous
villainous black knight from whom dane
inherits a castle and finds the ebony
blade which is where that post-credits
scene takes place in this scene he also
calls cersei king midas setting up her
reverse midacing timoth's golden body
into marble now when the deviants attack
the camp sprite clears karoon out of
there how many cameras did you bring
young man yeah i love how she calls him
young man and then keigo gets his big
move
issue
now deshome is a kind of onomatopoeia
that's used in bollywood movies for
flesh on flesh hits like kapow or blam
but this is my favorite kill of the
movie simply for the practical effect of
all that green blood spilling all over
kamehameha gianni's face cersei turns a
deviant into a tree showing that she
actually can transform sentient beings
despite her belief otherwise and of
course setting up her ability to do this
to tiamat the alpha deviant kills
gilgamesh and absorbs his life force
turning him into a more humanoid form of
crow voiced by pennywise actor bill
skarsgard who accuses the eternals of
hunting his kind you are not saviors
eternals you are murderers and then we
meet fastos at the site of hiroshima
august 8 1945 the day american forces
dropped an atomic bomb on the city
vastos tells his husband and son that
icarus and cersei are named isaac and
sylvia and nod their human aliases in
the comics of isaac ike harris and
sylvia cersei inside icarus reads a star
wars coloring book and then he wrecks
fastosa's table what's this even made of
vibranium
fall collection
ikea you could read this as a subtle
implication that vastos might have at
least helped the wakandans craft their
vibranium into the technology they have
they dig back up their domo ship in iraq
and join makari who wears a shirt for hg
wells war of the worlds a story with a
similar plot about extraterrestrial
world enders who end up unsuccessful
gingo calls her miss havisham
referencing the hoarder of charles
dickens great expectations and we see
makari has collected a ton of stuff from
throughout history an ancient egyptian
statue of the deity bastet a painting
called le lazande music which hangs in
the louvre a roman imperial eagle staff
with spqr for cenatus populis k romanus
a big mac and its carton the holy
freaking grail that's the same design
from indiana jones and last crusade the
chimera of a rezzo statue which in real
life resides the national archaeological
museum of florence a throne that is not
the uk st edwards chair but at least one
similar to it a medieval suit of armor
and a playstation vr headset dina and
sprite play with this stuff is that the
ebony blade excalibur
arthur always did have a crush on you
confirming that these eternals were
really part of dane's family history as
well and then icarus and drake trade
some twinkies for that emerald tablet
they were talking about before so let's
jump ahead to the emergence happening
makari sprints across the world and we
see some fun landmarks the glenfin
infinite viaduct of scotland and then
the chrysler redeemer statue of rio de
janeiro then she stops in the indian
ocean where we see some nearby oil
platforms drilling baby drilling this
could be a spot of the crust that is
filled with oil pockets making it a bit
thinner fatima to crash up through
during this battle cersei transfigures
the volcanic rock into a flock of birds
the same kind of move doctor strange
pulled against thanos and infinity war
making her that kind of doctor strange
wizard that dane accused her of being
are you a wizard like doctor strange and
during this final battle icarus angrily
fires his laser eyes at the sky evoking
an iconic frame of icarus from the
conics and tiamat rises out of the
indian ocean folks this is crazy it
really should create an insane seismic
event that would destroy most of the
planet but it looks awesome and i love
the fact that in the mcu now there is
just a giant celestial head in hand
poking out of the indian ocean in the
comics the corpse of a celestial is
actually used for avengers hq at some
point that'd be a really fun place to
put adventures hq now but cersei is a
victor of the hour she's the one who
transfigures them into marble and this
process is really a unimine that links
all of them including tiamat and we see
them being linked in the following order
cersei then druid then sprite then
fastos and makari then thena then icarus
if you think about it this was the same
exact order they were in back on the
domo in the opening sequence but of
course sadly ajak and gilgamesh removed
from that even in the unimine there is
an order of succession here now icarus
memories of cersei rewind backward
through their time together back to
their wedding day and their time in
babylon and the first moment they set
eyes on earth from space when cersei
said it's beautiful isn't it yes
reminded of the word beautiful the same
word that icarus tried to teach himself
in the babylonian language to cersei the
day he proposed leading him to fly into
the sun though i have a good feeling
this guy survived probably popped out
the other end with more powers but after
sprite is turned into immortal the movie
ends with athena drink and makari
departing earth on the domo to seek out
other eternals and other planets while
kingo sprite and cersei stay behind on
earth and in that final scene as dane
begins to tell cersei about his family
history being complicated clouds form in
the sky and airship appears zipping
cersei up to him along with bastos and
kingo and he says you have chosen to
sacrifice a celestial for the people of
this planet i will spare them but your
memories will show if they are worthy to
live and i will return for judgment
allowing him to complete his arc to
become his title from the comics
aeroshem the judge and rather than every
other time we've seen him disappear just
and out of view as if lowering a curtain
in front of him now we see him kind of
zip into his own black hole holding in
on himself now the post-credits scenes
introduce us to harry freaking styles as
eros brother to thanos and his buddy pip
the troll voiced by pat oswalt actually
learned of a conceived alternate ending
to this scene that was actually shot
according to lauren ridloff that would
have shown this group actually communing
with aresham and then of course the
second post-credits scene confirming
dean whitman's destiny as the black
knight finding the ebony blade and his
uncle nathan's mansion and i love the
little detail of the surface of that
blade reaching out to his fingers a
blade that is calling to him that's all
the new stuff i found and you can
support new rockstars by checking out
our merch options at
newrockstarsmerch.com follow me on
instagram and twitter at ea boss follow
new rockstars and subscribe for
breakdowns of everything you love thanks
for watching bye
[Music]
you